tras dos años de pandemia las cifras no
dan tregua en eeuu las hospitalizaciones
pediátricas se dispararon un 35 por
ciento como un promedio diario de 262
admisiones de jóvenes pacientes y la
semana previa a la navidad los números
rojos se concentran en new jersey nueva
york puerto rico y las islas vírgenes
esto mientras 52 millones de
estadounidenses han dado positivo en lo
que va de la pandemia y aunque rusia
registró una tendencia a la baja el
resto del mundo corre otra suerte en
españa' los medios de prensa destacan
cifras récord por primera vez se
registran más de 1000 infecciones por
cada 100.000 habitantes las pruebas
caseras gratuitas proporcionadas por el
gobierno regional de madrid escasean
una caja 2 4 6 8 10 20
y hay una cola esperando de 30 personas
australia marcó este martes un nuevo
récord de contagios
11.264 nuevos casos superando el pico de
la jornada anterior mientras en la
ciudad china de xian con 13 millones de
habitantes empezó una cuarentena
estricta tras registrar el brote más
importante del año
además de las restricciones de
actividades públicas y privadas que se
han dado mundialmente como en alemania
otras iniciativas menos convencionales
también marcan el segundo año de la
pandemia en sudáfrica los trabajadores
funerarios de soweto salieron a las
calles para promover la vacunación white
feather a la anda chica en por que una
funeraria se está embarcando en decirle
a la gente que se vacune no sería bueno
que la gente falleciera en el corte
inglés' en realidad no es bueno cuando
vemos vidas pareciendo así que eso es
parte de nuestra iniciativa hoy con más
de 5 millones de muertes registradas
mundialmente a causa del cobi las
autoridades insisten en que la manera
más efectiva de enfrentar la pandemia es
la vacunación en todo el planeta ya se
han administrado más de 9 mil millones
de dosis